CUBA, CRACKING DOWN ON RECENT
UNREST IN THE COUNTRY, AND
BLAMING IT ON THE U.S..
IT HAS ACCUSED THE U.S. OF
ECONOMIC ASPHYXIATION OVER
SANCTIONS, IMPOSED DURING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
U.S. OFFICIALS SAYING, THE
CUBAN GOVERNMENT SHOULD LISTEN
TO ITS OWN PEOPLE, INSTEAD.
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE A
GRIEVOUS MISTAKE FOR THE CUBAN
REGIME TO INTERPRET WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN DOZENS OF TOWNS,
AND CITIES, ACROSS THE ISLAND,
AS THE RESULT, OR PRODUCT, OF
ANYTHING THAT THE UNITED STATES
HAS DONE.
IT WOULD BE A GRIEVOUS MISTAKE
BECAUSE IT WOULD SHOW, SIMPLY,
THEY AREN'T HEARING THE VOICES,
AND THE WILL, OF THE CUBAN
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE, DEEPLY, DEEPLY, DEEPLY
TIRED OF THE REPRESSION THAT
HAS GONE ON FOR FAR TOO LONG.
>> THERE ARE REPORTS OF
INTERNET BLACKOUTS IN CUBA
AFTER THE PROTESTS, AND
ACCORDING TO THE EXILED RIGHTS
GROUP, AT LEAST 100 PROTESTERS,
ACTIVISTS, AND INDEPENDENT
JOURNALISTS HAVE BEEN DETAINED.
CNN'S PATRICK OPPMANN HAS MORE,
FROM HAVANA.
>> THE PROTESTS SWEPT ACROSS
CUBA, THE LARGEST AND DECADES.
STUNNING TO COMMUNIST RUN
GOVERNMENT.
AND, QUICKLY, TURNED VIOLENT.
DEMONSTRATORS PELTED PATROL
CARS WITH, STONE'S.
POLICE, FORCIBLY ARRESTING
SCHOOLS OF PEOPLE.
THE REPRESSION, THIS WOMAN TOLD
CNN.
ALL WE HAVE HERE IS REPRESSION.
COUNTER PROTESTERS, ORGANIZED
BY THE GOVERNMENT, TRYING TO
SHUT THEM DOWN.
SOME, CHANTING, THEY ARE FIDEL
CASTRO, BUT FIDEL CASTRO DIED
IN 2016, AND HIS BROTHER,
RETIRED IN APRIL.
NOW, THE JOB OF MANAGING CUBA'S
WORST CRISIS IN A GENERATION,
FALLING TO OUR HANDPICKED
SUCCESSOR.
WHO CALLED THE PROTESTERS
CRIMINALS.
THEY SAW A POLICE FORCE,
DAMAGED CARS, THEY SAID, A
BEHAVIOR THAT IS COMPLETELY
VULGAR, AND INDECENT.
TENSIONS HAVE BEEN BUILDING,
FOR MONTHS IN CUBA.
OVER INCREASED SANCTIONS, FIRST
IMPOSED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
IT IS FURTHER WOUNDED AND
ALREADY AILING ECONOMY.
CUBANS, WAITING FOR HOURS, IN
CROWDED LINES, EACH DAY, TO BUY
WHAT LITTLE THERE IS, AS THE
NUMBER OF COVID-19 CASES SURGE.
>> CUBA'S FOOD CRISIS,
APPEARING TO GET WORSE, AND
WORSE, AS THE PANDEMIC GOES ON
LONGER, AND LONGER.
THESE PEOPLE HERE SAY THAT THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE WAITING HOURS
IN THESE LINES, BUT THEY FEEL
THAT THE CHOICE THEY HAVE IS
RUNNING A RISK OF GETTING
INFECTED, OR GOING HUNGRY.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
WARNING THE CUBAN GOVERNMENT
NOT TO CRACK DOWN ON THE
PROTESTERS.
>> WE CALL ON THE GOVERNMENT,
THE GOVERNMENT OF CUBA TO
REFRAIN FROM VIOLENCE, THEY ARE
ATTEMPTS TO SILENCE THE PEOPLE
OF CUBA.
>> BUT AFTER A DAY OF ANGRY
CLASHES, THAT WARNING MAY HAVE
ALREADY FOLLOWED ON DEAF EARS.
PATRICK OPPMANN, CNN, HAVANA.
>> CUBA ISN'T THE ONLY COUNTRY
WHERE ECONOMIC UPHEAVAL IS
LINKED TO COVID.
OVER THE LAST YEAR, WE HAVE
SEEN PROTESTS ACROSS THE WORLD
WITH THE GOVERNMENT HANDLING OF
THE PANDEMIC.
OUT OF THE 5 COUNTRIES WITH THE
HIGHEST DEATH TOLLS, 3 SPOTS
BELONGED TO LATIN AMERICA.
BRAZIL, FACING A NEW COVID WAVE,
AND PROTESTERS HAVE DEMANDED
THAT PRESIDENT JAIR BOLSONARO
BE IMPEACHED, OR RESIGN, OVER
HIS HANDLING OF THE CRISIS.
IN COLUMBIA, HUMAN RIGHTS
GROUPS SEEM TO HAVE EXCESSIVE
FORCE INTO DEMONSTRATORS,
PROTESTING A PROPOSED TAX BILL.
CRITICS SAID, IT WOULD HURT THE
MIDDLE CLASS IN A COUNTRY
ALREADY STRUGGLING WITH COVID.
AND, IN VENEZUELA, THERE WERE
ALREADY SHORTAGES BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC.
HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH, WORN BACK
IN MARCH 2020, THE COUNTRY'S
HEALTH SYSTEM IS TEETERING ON
THE BRINK OF COLLAPSE.
>> FOR MORE ON THIS, LET'S
BRING IN CHRISTOPHER 17, A
SENIOR FELLOW IN LONDON.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU ROSEMARY.
>> WHY IS IT THAT THESE LEADERS,
ACROSS LATIN AMERICA, AND THE
CARIBBEAN, HAVE FAILED THEIR
PEOPLE SO MISERABLY, THAT THE
PANDEMIC ONLY HIGHLIGHTING HOW
THEY HAVE ABANDONED THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES, IN TERMS OF
HEALTH SERVICES, AND MEDICAL
SUPPLIES, FOOD, WATER, AND
OTHER BASIC NECESSITIES?
>> IT IS IMPORTANT TO GO BACK
TO 2019, THE END OF 2019, WHEN
THERE'S ALREADY A WAVE OF
PROTESTS.
PROTESTS IN CHILE, ECUADOR, THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
BOLIVIA, BUT FOR DIFFERENT
REASONS, THERE IS A RISING
MIDDLE CLASS, AND THERE IS A
QUALITY OF SOCIAL SERVICES THAT
IT DESERVED.
THE OF COURSE, THIS WAS ALL PUT
ON HOLD BECAUSE OF COVID.
SO, WHAT YOU HAVE IS A PRESSURE
COOKER.
THEY'RE NOW BEGINNING TO SEE
THAT BOIL OVER, AND WHAT IS
BEGINNING TO BE EXPOSED, AND A
LOT OF, THEM STRUCTURAL FLAWS
IN THE SYSTEM, THAT IS ALREADY
BEGINNING TO IDENTIFYING 2019.
AS YOU SAID, ACCESS TO SOCIAL
SERVICES, STATE CAPACITY,
SOCIAL SAFETY NETS, AND A LARGE
PART OF THIS IS YOU ASK WHY,
BECAUSE OVER 60% OF PEOPLE, IN
LATIN AMERICA, AND PLACES LIKE
IN RURAL BRAZIL, ARE PART OF
THE INFORMAL SECTOR.
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
INSURANCE, UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE, OR HEALTH INSURANCE.
SO, WHEN THESE COUNTRIES SHUT
DOWN, THEY JUST COULDN'T GO
BACK TO THEIR HOMES.
THEY LIVED ON A DAY-TO-DAY WAGE,
SO THEY NEEDED TO GO BACK TO
WORK.
SO, WE'RE SEEING NOT JUST THE
EFFECTS OF A WEAK HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM, BUT THERE'S ALSO A
SOCIAL SAFETY NET SYSTEM,
FORCING THESE PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK.
CONSEQUENTLY, WE'RE SEEING 80%
OF THE WORLD'S POPULATION, MORE
THAN 40% OF THE INFECTION
RATES.
>> THIS WAS THE FIRST MAJOR
PROTESTS IN CUBA, AND DECADES.
THEY'RE MARCHING FOR REGIME
CHANGE, AS THEY STRUGGLE TO
CONTAIN COVID THERE, THEY ARE
HURTING NOW, WITH FOOD
SHORTAGES, ENERGY BLACKOUTS,
RESTRICTIONS ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS, AND WHAT THEY CAN
REALISTICALLY ACHIEVE, OR
EXPECT, AND HOW DO YOU THINK
THE CUBAN GOVERNMENT TO GET THE
WORLD WATCHING SO CLOSELY RIGHT
NOW?
>> FOR ALL OF THE ILLS OF OTHER
COUNTRIES, AND THEIR
DEMOCRACIES, AND THEY ARE
NOMINALLY DEMOCRACIES AT LEAST,
THERE ARE ELECTIONS.
THAT PROVIDES A SAFETY VALVE
FOR PEOPLE'S DEMANDS.
IN CUBA, IT DOESN'T EXIST.
THEY HAVEN'T HAD A COMPETITIVE
ELECTION SINCE 1959, SINCE THE
REVOLUTION.
CONSEQUENTLY, VERY MUCH SPREAD
AND BROADER ISSUES FOR BETTER
HEALTH CARE, BETTER JOBS,
BETTER ACCESS TO FOOD, OR
SIMPLY CHALLENGES TO THE
REGIME.
REGIME LAST LIKE ANY GOVERNMENT
THAT IS FEELING THREATENED,
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T HAVE A
CAPACITY TO MEDIATE THOSE
DEMANDS.
SO IT IS CRACKING DOWN.
BUT AS MENTIONED BY PATRICK, IN
THE BEGINNING STORY, IS THAT
THE CASTRO'S HAVEN'T BEEN
AROUND.
THIS IS THE FIRST PROTEST, POST
CASTRO, AND SO THE PRESIDENT IS
DEMONSTRATING, AND SAID, THIS I
WILL RESPOND IN A REVOLUTIONARY
WAY.
WITH THAT MEANS IS HE'S NOT A
CHILD OF THE REVOLUTION, WILL
RESPOND THROUGH REPRESSIVE
TACTICS, AN IRON FIST THAT THE
CASTERS DID TO, AND HE HAS TO,
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T LOOK WEAK.
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING THAT MOVE
OVER 100 PROTESTERS JAILED.
>> IN THE WAKE OF THESE
UNPRECEDENTED PROTESTS ACROSS
CUBA, PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID,
U.S. BIDEN IS IN CUBA.
HE HASN'T DONE ANYTHING
CONCRETE TO HELP THEM SO FAR,
EVEN AFTER PROMISING TO REVERSE
TRUMP'S CUBAN POLICIES DURING
THE 2020 CAMPAIGN.
WHAT SHOULD BIDEN BE DOING
RIGHT NOW?
WHY DO YOU THINK HE HASN'T
ACTED ON THIS YET?
>> LET ME ANSWER THE LAST
QUESTION FIRST.
HE LARGELY AS AN ACTIVE ON
LIFTING THE EMBARGO, BECAUSE
IT'S A SERIES OF APPOINTMENTS.
CONFIRMED IN THE SENATE.
IN THE SENATE, AND THE
PROMINENT CUBAN AMERICAN,
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO FROM,
FLORIDA AND IN NEW JERSEY, IF
THEY'RE GOING TO TINKER WITH
THE EMBARGO OVER THEIR HEADS,
THEY'RE GOING TO HOLD UP THE
NOMINATIONS, AND PUT THEIR
AMBASSADORS IN PLACE.
THE PROBLEM IS, ALL THE SCHOOLS
HAVE BEEN TIGHTENED AS MUCH AS
THEY CAN UNDER THE TRUMP
EMBARGO.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY LEVERAGE TO
DO ANYTHING MORE.
AND THE JOB WILL INTERVENE, AND
GIVEN THIS CUBAN HISTORY, AND
IS TO SPENDING ON THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DID, REPEATEDLY,
WHICH IS CALLED THE CUBAN
GOVERNMENT NAMES, BASICALLY
ENGAGING IN REGIME CHANGE, AND
TALKING ABOUT THE LEGITIMACY OF
THESE DEMANDS, CITIZENS DEMANDS,
AND THEIR RIGHT